danielle es un campesino ha sembrado 12
filas de zanahorias en su campo cada
fila tiene 6 zanahorias cuántas
zanahorias ha sembrado daniel y vamos a
buscar visualizar este ejercicio de tal
manera que aquí tendríamos una
5 6 zanahorias es más vamos a ponerle
sus hojas para que se vean
más lindas nuestras zanahorias
aunque tenemos aquí 6 zanahorias esto
sería equivalente a una de las 12 filas
vamos entonces a crear las 12 filas de
manera visual para que sea mucho más
sencillo
tenemos dos filas
esta es nuestra tercera fila esta es la
cuarta fila
cinco filas
seis filas vamos a la mitad si vuelvo a
copiar y pegar el total de estas seis
filas ahora tendré 12 llevo 6 ahora
tendré 12 si simplemente duplicó esta
cantidad
seis filas más seis filas ahora tengo
doce filas
y vamos a hacer algo vamos a poner con
azul que ha sembrado 12 filas ok y cada
una tiene 6 zanahorias
así es que contamos las zanahorias es 1
2 3 4 5
6 zanahorias
y vamos a enumerar nuestras filas 1 2 3
4 5 6
8 9 10 11 12 filas
si yo quiero saber cuántas zanahorias en
total ha sembrado daniel pues
simplemente puedo decir son 12 filas por
pueden contar una una de las zanahorias
sin embargo bueno estaría un poco loco
hacer eso e imagínate si fueran números
más grandes que cualquiera números
enormes estar contando todas y cada una
de esas zanahorias y estaría de locos
pero afortunadamente tenemos las
multiplicaciones como una herramienta en
la vida para hacernos la vida mucho más
sencilla y en este caso poder llegar a
la conclusión y saber cuántas zanahorias
tenemos realmente lo que vamos a
multiplicar será 12 filas x
6 zanahorias
dos vidas por seis zanahorias o lo que
es lo mismo doce veces seis zanahorias
si ustedes recuerdan sus tablas de
multiplicar lo cual deberían de hacer
porque es uno de los
es uno de los beneficios a largo plazo
más grandes que vamos a tener
aprendernos las tablas de multiplicar te
juro que esto te va a hacer la vida
muchísimo más sencilla así es que nos
vamos a recordar nuestras tablas de
multiplicar y sabremos que 12 por 6 es
igual a es igual a 72 y con eso
tendremos nuestra respuesta 12 filas de
6 zanahorias nos da un total de 72
sana áreas
nos vemos en otro vídeo